I feel so cool welcome to 5 lambda hi
what are you doing we don't hit drinks
in here your parties must suck no we
don't throw parties here in the United
States sororities are not allowed to
throw parties on their own houses only
frat scam these are the sexist
restrictive system Warners our sorority
- can party the way that we want -
what's the name of our sorority Kappa
Kappa nu welcome to our sorority Kappa
nu
[Music]
we're never gonna sell a house with a
sorority living next door what are we
gonna do baby it's not that bad girls
are usually quiet they don't really take
hard drugs and they're much smarter no I
kill the girl we need somebody who can
relate to stupid young people
hey neighbors let's shut this [ __ ] down
[Music]
these guys is everyone you look like a
psychopath the clown man people love
clowns I got an idea we go with the air
bag trip that's not gonna work if it
were good guys why would it work for
girls guys are idiot it's a little hard
to call the cops without a phone
if dumbass those girls are out of
control they're using their sexuality
[Music]
you don't understand that there's no I
in sorting there's two actually there's
actually there's just one no that's a
why no in the middle that's a no oh t by
t wa surura city that's how you spell it
you think that titty is silent
that's something the world can no longer
tolerate
I know how much Bucky means you stay out